yeah welcome to the weekly pull after of
over a month we have all board the main
hose on here
I am Benny the comic story and that is
Rob from comics explain that is Sal from
topic pop hold on hold on pretty solid
intro yeah this is pretty followed in
true I watched it all that so games
playing this shouldn't be we tell you it
looks great Oh a little there's a delay
you know there's always a way I'm just
by that I see okay hi anyway I'm betting
the cosmic story and that is Robin
coming explain that is Sal from comic
club in that house from it's super
effective this week we don't have our
list of books that came out or go
through all the ones that Benny hasn't
read Deathstroke old man Logan
Marvel Zombies a prediction future
imperfect weird world Justice League
gods and monsters Gotham my bid night
Sinestro we are Robin Lando Calrissian
Grayson the amazing spider-man where the
monsters vote Martian Manhunter doom dr.
fate Gotham Academy well a canary birth
right birth right birth life and [ __ ]
planet but done and done alright we'll
see you guys next week and I bet there
were some people in the chat like what
are they really leaving the format just
a little just a little
today we are going to be discussing
ant-man but we are going to now start
opening every week with what are we
reading what are we injuring my god okay
so me fellas I guess Bob is gonna go
first
earlier today and we were on Bobby what
why are you guys calling me Uncle Bobby
you know what see that Uncle Bobby I did
a live stream Q&A and I was like my
knees not wait your furs to me is like
local Bobby your uncle booty and they
won't stop calling me that
released they don't call your dad and
dude you're really creeping me out
daddy Bobby oh my god I don't know if I
should be a god-king Bobby
are you done what the hell
go for it I guess they're sitting there
thinking of stuff is what you're doing I
Drive my brain is like happy today okay
so anyway I'm gonna Phelps everything
when I told him that I'm sorry Bobby go
get it all out get it all out man for
the record guys I was at VidCon all
weekend and I am burned out goofy and
giggly and I'm ready for a nap so okay
if you're done I'm done
I'm good Bobby you can go ahead and go
forward by are you serious it's Sally
Bobby and Foust tea please time so
anyway so so what's really funny is is
like as an avid Marvel fan girls like
actually at all all seniors just Rob to
turn up your mic input is it that quiet
laughing at Sally laughing at Sally when
you have made good movies apparently
pixel pixel was a travesty anyway so it
should be it's really better now guys if
it's not let me know but but it's like
an avid Marvel fan it really disappoints
me to say that there's like two titles
and Secret Wars that I care about
one is Infinity Gauntlet and the other
is old man Logan and that's it and I
guess the main man Logan is so good
oh oh man Logan is so good it's so solid
man it's I was really nervous about that
I was like are they gonna be able to
continue like what made old man Logan so
awesome and like the story you know when
they launched the the tie-ins and they
have like it's really really good
but yeah infinity gone what I like
because I like the idea of there being
like more than one Thanos and they're
all vying for the Infinity stones which
is a really cool concept I think that's
you yeah like with DC it kind of cracks
me up because I'm only reading like
Batman and Superman I'm reading Action
Comics a Superman and Detective Comics
to Batman and knowledge yeah that's
that's a favorite pick up Geoff Johns is
Justice League cuz it's like it ignores
everything you're reading and it's just
he that's the one with the dark side
Warren it is the dark side cuz there's
the Justice League of America which is
like so full of like philosophy don't
waste your time with that the Justice
League of America I have a feeling it's
just gonna it's good but I think it's
gonna end like Final Crisis with
somebody singing somebody death and
we're gonna be like yeah what it's not
gonna be that it's not gonna be that
cerebral like words like all those
different segments from time yeah and
Brian he's just drawing it no that's so
I could put the design about Darkseid
were to be honest like a doctor I'm
enjoying um I like where that's going
but it's just it's just popcorn fun yeah
I'm down also mr. miracle is cool since
when
and he was also cool in like the Batman
Superman like when they went to
apocalypse with Supergirl and stuff the
you know that book from the Longstreet I
feel like they're just kind of sure mr.
miracle and like who do we oh yeah it's
like a vision and they compute the
vision you know what happened Warner
Brothers found like a warehouse full of
unsold mr. miracle action figures and
they were like just put him in a whole
bunch of books just make him like what
it was like what's the character
nobody'll ever put cyborg replace him
with mr. miracle for like just a couple
of months just until we can unload these
he's these figures he's he's read these
green and yellow figures please
everyone's complaining with a mic input
let me do this I'm gonna reduce mine for
you guys no run that way we should all
use be on the same level sweet
yeah cuz right now my microphones turn
up as loud as it's gonna get I don't
know why but I don't know you know you
know just of all words I do I do that in
Skype no I reduced mine so that way they
can turn it up and I'm not overpowering
oh cool
oh well that's how I know I'm gonna say
what I'm reading at the moment yes and
it's gonna be the most predictable title
that from me
Teen Titans because if I don't care no
one else in the world well it's bad but
I'm reading it really like I know what
the teen titans is called the Teen
Titans
but really it's never been about being a
teenager it's always been it's been like
these kids that I just written like
young adults that kind of have to
function doing an adult's job and this
one's just kind of trying to do what
batgirls doing and not doing it well I
don't like the new book I don't I love
the last one even as convoluted and
weird as it got
I liked the I liked the old run and I
don't like the new run night mmm like
with the current one other Teen Titans I
don't know how many people are reading
and I don't particularly want to enter
spoiler territory but I wouldn't be
surprised if it ended soon and it was
replaced with a Young Justice title and
then it was also replaced with just a
Titans title so they would have a title
that's doing the job that Teen Titans is
suppose someone suggested that Skype
next was mess with the mixers and it did
so I fixed them so everyone's the
loudest because I lowered everything
everyone reduced their valiant like we
raise it all the way up and then I fixed
it so everyone's screaming turn down
your volume every boy whoever whoever
suggested that that was the mix-up yes
Skype messed it up again it's fixed now
okay okay then but you're going back to
what I was saying I wouldn't be
surprised if the tight Teen Titans is
canceled and was replaced with Young
Justice and the Teen Titans
but for everyone that doesn't know Young
Justice Comics I've never been the same
as the Young Justice cartoon they're
like really like the cartoony and fun in
the comics and I miss that other than
that a meeting bat my really good book
it's fun it's really really fun um it's
really refreshing compared to everything
else that's coming out in DC right
everything is definitely serious
I mean like I know Batman like Jim
Gordon's Batman right now and he's just
like it's pretty light-hearted like oh
yeah no I
the Batman with Jim Gordon I I'm
actually really liking cuz yeah I do a
lot of Batman on my channel and it's not
because I know Batman's gonna get fuses
because I love Batman but when you start
doing Batman weekly which I thought
would be a great idea you start just
seeing how broody Batman really can do
Batman like arc and it's like and he's
gonna be evil in meat maniacal that he's
gonna manipulate no look he's about to
cry all right well that's a problem I
have like like every Batman story Bruce
Wayne's always like I can always
overcome things because one either I'm
really really rich or to like I'm super
smart but yeah Gordon's like man I have
no idea what I'm doing right now but
we'll just wing it and see what happens
and that's what makes a story so good I
think yeah and I agree to know and I'm I
guess I guess technically it's my turn
or Sal did you go to cuz you gotta jump
down I got into everyone else's stuff
yeah yeah takeovers beginning he's now
cutting me off like what is this so rude
Faust I think my favorite title at the
moment from Marvel and DC it's like my
go-to title is giant sigh a little
Marvel I just think it's so good I want
more of it I want it to be like an
ongoing series a that past secret was
probably well maybe yeah really I'm
pretty much all the same stuff you guys
are old man Logan I'm reading the little
Marvel every a good chunk I'd say my
favorite ones right now has to be it is
gonna seem weird I'm really digging the
Batman Robert I'm diggin Superman I mean
I'm
really behind most of my DC books marvel
I'm really behind like spider what we
just had a great new book come out
ant-man I'm reading but oddly I like the
Spider Woman book you read it last week
I know it's not a road trip with grizzly
bear I stopped reading it around issues
oh no no this is now on a road trip with
grizzly bear so like though go to a
place he'll mess up horribly she has to
save him and he'll be like I'm trying to
be a good guy so they go to the next
place he'll mess up horribly she has to
save him I don't know why marble
something like grizzly bear needs to be
a thing like put him in a man put him in
a Spider Woman seem so treating it a
while ago and it was so bad like around
issue for it was like cuz they were
gonna cancel their issue 6 but it's got
it's kind of going in a direction kind
of like ant-man with Nick Spencer did
where it's kind of like fun and
happy-go-lucky the serious guys here oh
the series one for this one a Spider
Woman and she's stuck with a bunch of
idiots that's okay but no I'm really
liking that well but I'm actually
reading a lot of independent stuff
lately I've been going actually really
heavy into Turtles IDW is terrible
Turtles I love that people have been
asking like for a ninja tour I guess
I'll do the triangle someone turtles I
did the first book and I want to do more
I'm just waiting to get a hold of IDW
and kind of get a pseudo permission to
do it like we have with Marvel and DC
cuz I don't want to do stuff and then
then tell me no yeah but like turtles is
great I love it Turtles awesome I never
got into the Ninja Turtle comics I have
not read or had anything to do with a
ninja turtles in years so there's a few
things in there that I'm like really
then that's that's kind of crazy but
like that I love the reinvention of
everything that we knew as kids but not
in a bad way even the new origin kind of
which matches more in line with the
movie
sadly but then what's a good jumping on
it like I mean not valiant a little
while ago they had a sale at comiXology
I was like 75% off all of them so I
didn't want selection and all of these
trips I keep reading it on the plane and
I just caught all the way up to the the
death of Dom Selim so Donatello dies
spoilers thanks dude Brittany how did
you miss that two months ago I'm putting
them
people were asking me in the chat and
the Congress got where they were like
you should do a video on the death about
a fellow and I was like uh-uh I didn't
know but okay that's the thing people
don't realize we don't read things
straight away like they think we do so
like we can't avoid spoilers if you do
you cheer oh yeah oh you guys especially
especially like and breaking news you
guys know normally most telling us in
the chat but anyway uh yeah i know the
trolls is great the reinvention of the
origins awesome cuz it takes the same
concept as the movie where they're
Turtles I got the is and they just
learned it in the sewer but they
explained how that worked by explaining
they are the reincarnation of like a
ninja family that was wrongfully killed
by shredder and they're destined to
constantly reincarnate and fight him now
oh line two Zelda so the turtles are now
Zelda nobody reading that and then
thanks to actually uh comic pops indie
indie corner thing I've been reading
[ __ ] planet thanks to Tiffany and I
actually picked up 21st century Tank
Girl oh cool I've never had interest in
tank girls so I'm interested in here
they what that's no it's actually
interesting like there's no actual art
it's like three stories per issue okay
you just get like a five page story of
Tank Girl just being insane and crazy
and fun good there's no nothing like
that I mean there's gratuitous nudity
and all kinds of crazy stuff but hey
girl should be like a heavy metal book
yeah that basically is yeah yeah wow
that's awesome
teenage mutant Zelda turtles decisions
oh here's the other thing um oh my god
way back in red bizarro number one for
DC oh hey yeah and because I think I'm
her fur was you Sal or somebody with
they were like bizarro number one's
really good like it really was me I
thought it was really entertaining it
was funny like see bizarro just like on
the road to likely with the road yeah it
was it was really funny and like the the
the king whatever it is the car lot
salesman that's like empowered by aliens
they're like take this stuff and it'll
make you powerful and that was that was
pretty funny but I like the I mean I
don't I never really got into the Zara
comics before so I don't know what they
were like before but to see like a
bizarro that
like where he's intentionally drawn to
look goofy you know and it's silly and
it's nonsensical is really entertaining
to me so give me that to me that's not
what we're supposed to be like he's a
goofy version of Superman so typically
when they do bizarro it's like cuz he
cuz he is a silly character like the
idea of a like a me am so happy to fight
you like what because it's such a dorky
goofy premise the like they usually tend
to and I think this is actually all over
from like the Superman animated series
like go really dark like he's a botched
clone of Superman and he's like you know
what I mean like it's just he they tend
to go like we're kind of Solomon Grundy
slash like just make him a really tragic
story where he desperately wants to do
good but he's wired to be opposite and
he's just a freak I'm like that's a neat
idea in like nineteen ninety five
dollars but like in today's world it's
kind of depressing what I like about was
ro and I actually love that book I love
the whole Jimmy Olsen hammer going
across the world they fight like this
fake Tutankhamun guy and yeah I go carry
the weird stuff um what I oughta find by
weird about those they tried to reinvent
bizarro during forever evil Lex's have
had a new clone and he was that guy he
was wired to be bad wanted to be good
and it's almost like they're just like
yeah he didn't exist
here's bizarro like I'll say that it's
entertaining and here's one of the funny
things somebody asked me in the in the
converse coffee livestream they were
asking about like what they what I
thought about DC you know I'm gonna make
a video kind of explain the difference
between that and new 52 but I think a
lot of people are confused like is DC
you like a reboot it's like really a
reboot just so much as a new series of
stories but like I like the idea of DC
you and so far that there's different
things for different people the problem
is I don't care about like 90% of the
stuff that's out the one title where I
was like I know I'm gonna like this and
really looking forward to like this was
postponed till October it was mystic you
I was like it's gonna like explore the
magical side of the DC universe and put
all like magical characters that are
there but you kind of forget about in a
school and apparently rumors are going
around that it stars
Timothy hunter from the books of magic
series
so I really was looking forward to that
one and it's not there so I'm just kind
of bitter yeah this actually fits kind
of like how do you feel about Gotham
Academy I think I might have asked you
this before or on the podcast or not you
might as though oh yeah I know
I like his mom Becky Cloonan went on
Twitter like a few months ago and she's
like please read Gotham Academy anyone
who wants to read it I'll send you
copies of the book and we reached out to
her and she was like here you go I I
jumped on board at the Damian Wayne Art
a little single-issue and I loved it
this like I'm buying the book six issues
and I'm like this is a really good book
it's like it's like an anime Harry
Potter and yeah yeah I think you're I
always say like if you're an anime fan
that says oh I don't really read comics
I just say there's a comic there for you
yeah it's called Gotham Academy that an
earth true Society is drawn up entirely
like an anime I don't read anything
called earth to ever since for every
future imperfect and after convergence
I'll never read another earth to book
again really I don't know I'd like to
see to me what's what's cool is the only
reason why I'm reading Superman I'll say
this the only reason why why I'm reading
Superman right now it's because I've
said it before it's the most compelling
Superman story I've read in a long time
because Superman is how do you write a
Superman story that's interesting you've
got a guy that could do anything and as
long as you don't have kryptonite in
your hand you're probably gonna get beat
so how do you write a story that's
interesting like that well you take his
powers away well I'm down with that and
then then you tell everybody what his
identity is which is which as far as I
understand they still haven't revealed
how that happened all they revealed is
that Lois Lane figured out his identity
when he was dressed as Clark Kent when
he lost his powers temporarily yeah they
they slightly revealed and you can kind
of assume where it's gonna go
but I forget which one of the Superman
books it is the latest issue revealed
like before all this happened and what
they show is somebody learned his
identity and pretty much had him by the
balls it was like you have to do what I
say or I'm gonna reveal it to the world
oh here's a mini walked away and said
that's right so you can almost assume
that it's gonna be a lowest reveal it
for me so this guy can't make me do
something okay yeah that's that's a good
call but oh
I don't know I was gonna change subject
but keep talking no no but I like that
idea I like the idea of a powerless
Superman and how eat it well not really
powerless he still has powers he is not
nearly as strong as he was but I like
the idea of like it in hands do what
yeah he's just he's muted like yeah he's
wanted purposes just a really really dig
he's like Luke Cage that powerful like
yeah yeah he's just like a you're still
not gonna go arm wrestle the guy bullets
can slow him the hell down yeah wait he
saw that and I think it was Superman
Wonder Woman
he got shot up by a bunch of armor but
you said once a dead shot yeah
so it actually just damaged like he was
like don't see me I will say one book at
the moment that I was surprised
I'm liking as much as I am and I've
totally forgot to mention it is Martian
Manhunter didn't care for the pacings
weird oh right that but other than that
I'm kind of sure I want to know where
the story goes they that's why as I am
enjoying it cuz I'm curious it brings me
back
having that yeah it's pacing is really
weird but there's at the same time it's
pacing isn't as bad as the flash at the
moment cuz for a book called the flash
the pacing is slow I love the flash but
it should not take like I think the
first major arc concluded after like 22
freakin issues and then the second major
arc was like 18 inches long and like
we're in the second issue now and
they're like professor zooms back and
I'm like so he's gonna do something at
night issues like doing here who's in
the flash right now they changed writers
I think I got it somewhere no I don't
have it here I think they changed us how
that guy I don't think it was the guy
who was doing it last time but either
way like it's it's it's interesting to
me I mean I love the whole Superman true
the idea who I love that whole concept
and that's why I think that that those
stories are doing good right now the
question is can DC hold that or as DC
gonna screw it up
like are they gonna mess that up because
I like how do you I mean what okay what
direction do you take this thing
I mean let's let's say that like I mean
let's say right now we're deciding what
direction the story goes in like what
happens to Superman get his powers back
did he just
cuz right now he's not even Golden Age
Superman I mean Golden Age teen I could
jump over buildings like he can't even
do that so the question is like you know
where do you take this to you kind of
restore his powers to a miniscule level
does he get his powers back entirely and
how does he get them back you know I
hope I was real quick for the record
just answer that question francis
manipul i can't pronounce the last name
but the guy who was writing the flash
the story arcs i liked he moved last
year to Detective Comics maybe I should
read detective if he's writing detective
comics right now he's doing a good job
right now it's awesome
yeah yeah I think like for Superman to
get his powers restored there was a
similar idea and the 90s with or it was
a tooth that 2003 Linda Danvers
basically lost her powers as Supergirl
and essentially you had the powers that
Superman has at the moment and she
needed to be healed by something that
wasn't of this universe which turned out
to be matrix and that was the second
time she was killed by oh yeah and she
got her powers restored so I think they
could just be rehashing that and hoping
no one notices which is why I'm not
feeling Superman at the moment you are
aware they took super girls powers too
right no that's one of the books and I
run all the way to the end before they
cancelled and said it's done at the very
end of the whole thing they wrapped up
all the story works ever happening she
goes back down to earth and they end it
with her cutting her finger with a paper
cut and if she's like what is this and
then it cuts to the bottom says the end
with a question mark Supergirl will
return or something like that and I'm
assuming they're just holding for the
show but then Supergirl is coming back
in Justice League book with all her
powers
yeah about stories they're not worried
about the way like here's what I like
about it and actually I think I'm taking
this from a review you had in your
channel so um DC's pretty much writing
books for everybody now so if you want
to see a compelling Superman story go
read Superman but if you want to see
Superman a Batman in their current
it's doing the amazing stuff you have a
dark side war and Justice League of
America yeah you know the same thing
with Supergirl while her story might
focus on her losing her powers in
getting normal life and probably
matching a lot to what's going on the TV
show
she might be on a Justice League book
and just have a power thing that's right
yeah like they could legitimately do
anything they want depending on the
title so then the thing at the same time
I don't see this lasting cuz they're
already sort of falling back into
continuity we've seen the books that are
being released in October we're talking
about Batman and Jim Gordon and how he
took over you could feel like he's been
he's been bad make like three issues max
and like you could feel that they're
gonna that they're gonna fix that
they're gonna fix it and put him back
like get rid of him and then the
comments lit up and they were like
apparently Snyder said in an interview
in like six months
Gordon's Batman for six months that's it
well yeah like we know that because of
the way way Detective Comics ended I
think it was where Jim Gordon yet like
went to go find Bruce Wayne is like I
know where you are you know and like I
need your help or something like that
I'm like well I guess things coming back
oh yeah oh yeah no it was the end of the
end of the latest Batman issue whichever
was like it's amazing and I was like I
really like this is cool they don't have
to do that like because it's DC you like
it's not like people are it's not like
this is the only book that has freaking
Batman in it right and you could I mean
this funny others I mean like you prove
it with superior spider-man apparently
that was supposed to be like maybe six
issues and then they were like can you
squeeze another year out of this and
he's like I'm Dan Slott of course I can
literally make anything I can make spy I
can make lemonade out of anything called
spider-man like you got so he stretched
that up for a year and like proved that
not only can you do it but you can do
kind of well until chemically drowsy and
then and you could literally do like
like with the with the reveal at the end
of Justice League and I want to ruin it
if everyone has read it like the end of
Justice League I'm like not of America
just Justice League
I'm like I can't wait to see the next
issue oh yeah dude dude okay wait on top
yes any two hearts fantastic in the
stories without this isn't major
spoilers it is one comment that he made
now I want to know if the people who
have read it think that we're gonna get
more to this before we go to a men who
want her next time he makes a comment at
the ending he I'm not gonna spin how it
happened but he basically has knowledge
at his fingertips and he's like what's
the Joker's name and then he goes no
they're gonna give us a quality Oh
Bambi's just gonna know it or when he
loses the ability to know it he won't
know it anymore
either way it's gonna be like is this
gonna be like Nick Fury talking to Thor
we're just chasing Aaron by God yeah you
do nothing before you end the Thor
series for the love of God please tell
us what the hell Nick Fury said a thorn
I'm getting harassed reference I'm gonna
tell you right now if I upload a video
that's titled here's what Nick Fury said
to Thor it's gonna get a million views
actually it's gonna blow up so bad
because everybody wants to know okay but
here's here's the thing before we move
on here's here's one thing I wanted to
say when it comes to the when it comes
to DC one of the things that I love the
most about DC but it's so hard for me to
cope with as a hardcore Marvel fan is
how different things are like DC's
character story arcs and it took a long
time for me to to get used to that too
here is a character it's like it's like
Marvel Tribe do that with Cyclops and it
was a total catastrophe because Cyclops
sucks but like they they try to do like
like individual characters stories of
Marvel and I'm so used to like crossover
events like all of Marvel's arcs are
like group crossovers x-men vs. I
understand that finiti and so on and so
forth they've been doing that a lot
lately and not just a cyclops a lot of
the the better books and recently Marvel
have been just individual arts like Miss
Marvel Thor like they don't cross over
it's just what's happening in that book
yeah but we've been reading yeah like
when you were reading Marvel for a long
time and and all you have are like a
litany of major crossover events going
back years and years and years and then
you say okay let's just go read some DC
comics
and it's like well Superman's got a
major character crossover and you might
see Batman but you probably won't like
then it's like okay I mean it's it's
weird to get used to its it's weird to
to like adjust to that but once you do
like when I was able to adjust to it
it's amazing like DC you have some
really really solid character arcs and
that's why I think I dig it so much is
because it's so easy to say like here's
a video on the flash and here's like
three character arcs you know on the
character or something like that it's so
easy to you know like just from a reader
standpoint and like an adjustment
adjustment standpoint like it's it's
really cool to get behind and that's
what I like I think about DC so much is
that it's just focused so much on
characters as opposed to major crime me
I guess unless you're reading justice
league yeah I will say sometimes they
that kind of hurts them like with the
Suicide Squad book that because that
focus on characters normally shifts in
Greek books but with the Suicide Squad
but it never shifted it was always Holly
Quinn and those Suicide Squad guys or
whatever someone was saying how DC you
we don't care about continuity mortals
doing the exact same thing as of October
um I'm Marvel has released a bunch of
the books that are coming out in October
and they all don't match up and this
that's gonna be doing I'm gonna tell you
right now that's a huge gamble for
Marvel so like your continuity out the
window
and to say I think in general people are
getting tired of continuity I think that
is just coming down people are getting
tired of questioning where does that
where did Batman fight this do that the
other thing they just want their stories
like it's always been a question of
spider-man you know for Marvel it was
always like spider-man Wolverine an
ongoing joke oh they're on every team
and they're here and they're there oh
and between that ephod Green Goblin it's
all good
which kind of sucks for us because when
we tell like the history of these
characters it's gonna like and then we
get to the point where continuity
doesn't matter I did it I did a joke on
that on the gaming channel a long time
ago before we did the comic channel but
I did the story of Mario so I was like I
told the continuity story of Mario and
then like between like a major gap in
the games I'm like and during this
period Mario and his friends played dope
kart racing 10
soccer everything into one they just
took a lot of vacations I agree that I
think like hot annuity is a huge
stickler for a lot of people because it
makes things make sense you know and and
that's why you can go and read more
alike like for example people say okay
I'm like people were asking me the
question so I actually tweeted to me the
question of you know do they do that the
x-men have a version of Civil War and I
was like yes it was called decimation
and like that's like decimation took
them out of Civil War and it you
remember continuity pepperidge farm
remembers consignee yes yes schism to a
degree when they split the schools down
the middle but yeah okay I guess it's a
really good version but the fact remains
like like you can literally you can read
Civil War annihilation and decimation
and no those three are all going on at
the same time you know and it makes
sense you know the way they're done like
it's all going on at the same time you
know that's why you know Tony Stark went
to go visit in frost and she's like get
out of here we don't have anything to do
with that we got bigger fish to fry than
your stupid Civil War so you know all
those things line up it makes sense
um I think that when when people start
reading through stuff because they're
even doing it now a civil war with a
secret wars they gave Secret Wars and
you have old man Logan who's literally
going from one reality to the next like
one world to the next and so people like
okay all these things line up it's the
most continuity that you have in the
story right now but you know it's
continuity nonetheless and so if they
walk away from all of that and they say
here's just like a whole bunch of
stories you know and they may or may not
line up then that's gonna be a huge
gamble that being said I think a great
break away from their history is exactly
what they mean and I think a good
decision well you gotta think you know
what and we're getting what's known as
you vent burnout or what's it called
like exhaustion because we went from I
don't remember where it was with this
time last year we were on a different
event moved right into original sin
right into axis or right into stupid
wars prep and into secret Wars like I
don't care anymore
yeah just give me fun stories I think
that's why I love Miss marbles so much
and why I love no seriously and why I
like Thor so much and why
liking spidery because they're like
they're not in that I could just get a
story oh okay I wanted to say this too
because somebody asked me about it um
Deadpool's secret secret war is that not
an amazing story oh it's one of the best
Deadpool stories written in a long time
the best part about it is we're at least
getting that because the mrs. Deadpool
and Howling Commandos new soul read this
is garbage
I gave up with a suitable one I was like
no not doing it why would you have a
Deadpool book you make him that ghost in
the background but anyway right what if
mrs. call it lady whatever name is and
Deadpool is a main character in that
book he's actively participating in that
book he's a ghost but it's like he is
fun and that he's written fun in that K
in that book I really just like to read
panels an issue yes so listen that's
called a cameo you have you have you
have forests worth of Deadpool action
and you can enjoy literally forests were
not enough though it's more than enough
I want more dead bull goddammit then go
see the friggin movie because that's our
books of the week we will learn how to
condense that a lot shorter than 40
freakin minutes but alright guys moving
on to the next topic it's time to talk
about the biggest small guy in the world
this is going to be open spoilers
because it's been like what are we gonna
hatch system uber came out now yes yes
Ben are we gonna have your coven you've
only seen it twice oh no he's right now
he's right so at this point this is your
warning if you don't want spoilers rant
man take off yeah
twenty or thirty minutes talking ant-man
first I'll give you a big wait I'll be
like no you can come back firstly first
eternity wasn't a min like like the
director Paul Reid is like yeah
basically yeah or whatever his name is
Paul never pay Peyton Reed was like you
know pretty much okay you you set that
in the chat and then I went go again to
go and see it today and I
we forgot to look out for a tenant but
is it the part ways just getting smaller
and smaller and smaller yeah I don't
think that is because everyone's but
okay but first off wait we're gonna pray
we're jumping right into Easter eggs but
crap I saw at the very end of the movie
when he's going into shrinking into
oblivion I've seen multiple things
because the director said watch for
stuff in that scene now I've heard you
said eternity beer the only one I've
ever heard say that everybody else that
I've read Easter eggs on says that you
can see Janet Van Dyne you can see an
image of the wasp hmm that's eternity as
everything why would he turn a little
eat the wasp I would be what mix that up
no because it was maybe he was with the
wasp is eternity in this I think it
looks like eternity I really I
we're not gonna get an answer until a
man - they told us about the about the
we know that cosmic entities exist they
told us about it and guardians of the
galaxy know all that kind of stuff and
they were like here's the four cosmic
entities they made the Infinity stone so
on and so forth like we know they were
there like we know infinity eternity
mistress death and Oblivion which is
entropy whatever like they're there you
know so we know we have four of the
cosmic way yeah but they're only
mentions of briefly guardians I think
it'd be so weird to put him into the end
of an ant-man movie oh did you I get the
guardians like collectors things like
the good ones all that stuff all that
lowered like they do actually yeah no I
know it's put in there no I just find I
think it would be weird to put eternity
into the ant-man movie like it just
seems so out of place I don't think so
even as an easter egg you're talking
okay you're talking about a movie where
a guy shrinks down to a miniscule
mystery the Microverse
and you're gonna tell me it's weird to
have eternity in the movie you're like
what's his name when he directed the
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
and was like I don't want a giant purple
alien in my film well you gotta guy this
make a fire you gotta do the stretches
bro that goes invisible is it really
that outrageous like is it really that
crazy
plus the guy that's made of silver okay
well okay so there is something at the
end there like I said every report that
I've seen stay stood it's the wasp I'm
not denying you because I don't remember
that scene at all like it's one of those
ones were
I looked it up afterwards and I'm like
how did I miss that but I'm not saying
you're wrong
I'm just saying everything else that
I've read states that it's the wasa that
is shown in not eternity yeah but then
again it could very well be a thing of
no one knows it charted it looks like I
said you only words in the world that
can identify like the directors gonna
come at me like you're all wrong
comics explain at it let's how about we
rewind and go from the ending of the
movie to the beginning of the movie what
did you guys think of their use of Hank
Pym as ant-man as a world war ii hero
awesome that retired awesomely it was an
awesome idea
I remember hearing that rumor like
before they even started like production
and I was like yeah it sounds awesome
like that ant-man had been fighting like
with like with uh with agent Carter like
yes even no way you know I didn't of you
guys read the pre lead comic no yeah
yeah of course not who reads prelude
Comics Marvel never does a good Chum no
they they what they give you some cool
information it's basically saying that
like he was part of the Cold War you
know I don't read those because here's
the short version because I while it
gives you information the director can
always just change his mind like the
movie people can be like what there's a
cop I don't care about that like it's
why I don't read the Star Trek like
movie tie-ins cuz I know that like the
next movie will just be like no well
that's kind of on a side note that's
kind of what I'm worried about the Star
Wars comics yeah those are in continuity
I'm like until they decide they're not
like sure Marvel is publishing them and
they're owned by Disney so technically
it's always you do you think I know they
have like a cabal of Star Wars nerds
that are like sifting through continuity
but if they're keeping Jar Jar Binks
they're not reading the friggin Marvel
Comics yeah they're keeping charge
debates because they're keeping the
prequels but they should have said when
they start it out when they're like
we're making the we're making seven
eight nine they should've been like and
one two three never happened
well okay we're not going talking about
this very long because we can have a
whole discussion I am gonna say this I
understand that throwing out all the
extended continuity movies that's gonna
be hard to just say yeah they have to
say like the only things that matter or
the movies and the shows we're making
right and I can see that you know even
though one two three we're god-awful you
really can't just be like ignore that
can and you know Sony does that with
spider-man they're gonna do after seven
eight nine they're gonna go like the man
of remake one two and three the mic drop
event at San Diego comic-con 2029 or
whatever will be like will just be Star
Wars it'll say one and they're gonna be
like you guys liked how I because
personally I thought I was gonna hate
him the fact and how they handle hate
him and in the end I freaking loved it
like love cuz that game was a great
excuse for Hank Pym and Scott Lang
because if you read the ant-man annual
they're always kind of weird they're
like the same age and hang around
forever Scott Lang hasn't
well it was a great it was it was a
great way to wrap it up because I mean
my question was like how do you
introduce Hank Pym as previously being
ant-man and then have Scott Lang take
over the mantle like how do you how do
you do that and I thought maybe they
were gonna do in the opening credits
member they're gonna do something
whatever or you know I'm up until the
point that I saw they were gonna have an
older ant-man then the question becomes
okay
what happened you know during this time
but doctor they wrapped it all up said
he was part of the Cold War era he was
ant-man during that time and just quit
because he was tired of doing it is an
awesome concept and I guess you know
Janet Van Dyne to like the way they
wrapped his character up really fast and
really neat left no questions like what
in the heck is going on like you know
what I don't understand what was going
on with Hank Pym previously and answered
all of your questions over the course of
the film there's one thing about that
that I had an issue with if I can just
jump on that and it's when he said that
the suit like the reason why he's not
doing it is because the suit took its
toll yeah because if he had said the
suit took its toll and I fixed it too
late then it'd be fine but like at no
point to Scott go like look it's like
does it give you cancer does it make me
look like Michael Blake does it make me
look like Kirk like Kirk Douglas because
that's what it seems to be doing tonight
I assumed by the
vacation with that he's just like there
wasn't as many safety things on it and
then with the loss of Janet he was like
alright it took its toll emotionally
basically it's implied but we literally
have a scene with like we have we've
three continuity dump scenes one after
the other where we have like we have we
have hope go like you never told me
about my mom and then we have Hank oh
let me tell you about your mom and then
we have like literally we have all the
plot has to take place in this one 12
minute long chunk of the movie and we
couldn't have any point where he's like
oh yeah about that suit that you said
took it so can we just make sure that we
guys all the do I it says the Pym
particles make me like say core can I
like he's a gonna shrink my junk and I
guess or even a reference because like
one of the things that I saw like red
letter media did all the thing about
ant-man and they're like why does he
have a helmet and I realized at that
point that at no point do they say you
have to breathe Pym particles in like
the one thing I will say about like that
section is as a whole is I don't think
that he would have asked that from
seeing the movie because he wasn't doing
this for himself at the end of the day
he was doing it so he was direct prison
so he could save his daughter so I don't
even or so he could like be with his
daughter so I I don't even think that oh
this is gonna hurt me is crossing his
mind because he's going into this going
I could die so I could see where sounds
coming from because I could be like yeah
I'm doing this entirely for my daughter
trying to take care of her it's gonna
take its toll so does that mean I have a
week or like 10 years right on existing
information in the comics like in the
comics like we know the Cardinals don't
we give you cancer
no but if you if you expose yourself to
Pym particles long enough like you don't
need Pym particles anymore now sometimes
Janet Van Dyne like she was explodes
yeah it's really fast the Pym particles
for so long that it was part of her body
she could have shrink down to lost many
times she wanted to so like I mean
that's that's kind of what I assumed
that they were talking about but it
would have been nice if they had done
something to explain there's enough like
implied and there's also enough of it
being a fun quasi comedy action movie
for you to really not care that's just
me being a nerd
and maybe this is one of the cutscenes
because I don't know about you but
almost all the trailer scenes were cut
out of the final cut
yeah they weren't there all the jokes
the can we change the name
oh I named it I noticed that any other
was great yeah any of the
self-deprecating anti ant-man jokes that
you would have expected that we're not
only in the trailer but you would have
expected in a movie that wasn't really
sure of itself we're gone and it's
almost like because the test audiences
were like don't be ashamed of making an
ant-man movie go see you know they'll
[ __ ] they're freaking go we're not
allowed to swear again we're on normal
hours Sal but no likely I mean it was
like that that is something that I
wouldn't have mind seeing but I mean
truth aside from that there really
weren't a whole lot of holes and I could
punch of the movie it didn't hurt the
movie at all from yeah I have no the
only thing the other thing that I had a
problem or and not a problem or like
it's too bad they didn't do this because
it once like it's like every every time
they release a Marvel movie they take
the same article they were printing for
the last 10 years and they just change
the name and they go why can't Marvel
make a long-standing villain like why is
Loki the only villain that you can have
because literally in every Marvel movie
they kill the bad guy like in every
super deal even Ultron you thought you
think ultra would hung around Loki us
you know they were no no I hope they
kill him too like everyone's dead
there's no long standing standing
villains and I remember hearing like
Jeff Bridges saying like I would have
loved to come back and been more Iron
Monger and I'm like that's fine but like
the character they didn't kill that I
would have loved to have seen in this
movie because of its tone is Justin
Hammer aka Sam Rockwell like Sam
Rockwell steals the show for Iron Man 2
Iron Man 2 is like worth watching just
to watch Justin Hammer true scenery and
it's so DS so funny and he's like it's
it's I mean like Ant Man is more or less
like another Iron Man's it's about a
billionaire industrialist who's fighting
hands another billionaire industrialist
and they've got suits and they have to
fight each other in their suits like
it's the same damn thing but totally
different and a lot of fun you take this
guy like you have Justin Hammer and he
like you could legitimately just have
him at the end of Iron Man to be like I
can't beat a Tony Stark but I could
probably be that PIM guy just invest all
his money into stealing Pym particles
and then he may and then you have a
hilarious Yellow Jacket I see I don't
know about that though because I mean
even Falcon couldn't beat him well no he
couldn't beat no Falcon couldn't beat
ant-man right but I'm saying like yeah
of course though yeah I see so you're
saying like if if Falcon couldn't beat
ant-man then definitely Justin Hammer
wouldn't be able to be well I would just
know because well he didn't see that
fight but like Justin hammers also like
us like a jackass and he's really full
of himself so like of course you would
think you could be him especially
because he's fighting against number
what he's not sure he doesn't know that
animate exists number two it's Ant Man
like you can't underestimate him but
then it allows him to not only not die
at the end of that but then you can
carry over Justin Hammer where he's this
disgruntled constantly battered loser
villain who's always trot like you could
bring him all the way into the daredevil
show it was like we don't know he's like
you can look maybe I could beat this
stupid guy in a ninja costume and then
you can make him into another hilarious
villain like you know you just take a
character that's who cares like about
Justin Hammer he's a great character I'm
just upset that he's only in that we're
Justin Hammer and everything he's just
the main villain for everyone you always
have that jokey villain that shows up
like who was the best one actually it
was reversed but um Ant Man Scott Lang
confronts taskmaster and he's like we're
arch nemesis and he's like I was there
for the other guys you were just you
were not there I was not your
arch-nemesis chat who's who's the
villain in ultimate spider-man that he
always beats his name's Herman I think
it was the shocker and like it is always
a shocker joke every three issues
spider-man beats shocker and it gets the
point where he eventually just like
kidnaps him and ties don't share and
he's like he's beats on him where he's
like I hate you so much every day you
defeat me
I love that that element I wish that was
min more comics like I wanted that in
spider-man 3 so bad
like for Ben Kingsley's OVAs the vulture
and just a spider-man your arch nemesis
is here inspires webs in one time and
then beats him and then he was like
where are these guys all come from said
we have we have aware of these guys I'll
come from as the main villain
we have Sandman be the whole movie reel
this back into a movie that came out in
the last couple of weeks it was the end
of my point oh and what and to go with
that point how did you feel about the
complete reinvention of a Scott Lang
villain into this normal guy who's got a
grudge against Hank Pym makes a crazy
yellow jacket suit yeah
alright here's just a problem that
Marvel has with those movies the villain
of Darren cross was cool like I'll tell
you this much this character this
version of Darren cross it sure as hell
had a lot more to him than the one in
the comics is he was there fishes and
then he died he was scary and funny and
but he makes sense like Marvel wasted
him so bad because I can't were the name
of the guy who played Eric Ross but he
is such a great actor like I mean in
house of cards who was amazing like he
is easily a villain that I would love to
have seen come back you know on like
several occasions doesn't matter win I
mean it several occasions you could tie
him into Tony Stark and say well now
he's the one that instigates the armor
Wars instead of like Justin Hammer I
mean you could do like oz number yeah
you could do any number of things like
that would be so cool the problem is and
this is this is I swear to this day it
will always be the plague of Marvel the
marvel cinematic universes existence
they can't take villains from the comics
and take their compelling nature and put
it in the films the only exception to
that is a kingpin that's because they
had 20 hours to achieve that like David
like the cool thing about the villains
and I mean it may be just a byproduct of
the comics because you can write so much
localized backstory endlessly so you can
do so much with them you know is you can
do that in the comics and the movies the
it seems like the villains are here for
the sole purpose of saying this is the
line of dichotomy between the good guy
and the bad guy like this guy's bad
because he does this stuff this is a
good guy let's focus on him and they
just put the bad guy in there for the
good guy to have someone to fight to
give the movie some semblance of purpose
to fill some formulaic you know standard
on how to make movies and I hate that
like I love oh well hopefully with the
advent of the spider-man franchise we'll
get like repeat Vil
because you can't kill Doctor Octopus I
don't care spider-man to fans but you
can still supply dr. Ives the deer need
a movie they're splitting in two fins I
didn't know the rich buttery - I liked
it when it first came out because there
was nothing to compare it to it was
great okay so by all three of the
spider-man 2 fans would be angry more U
is for mm-hmm then we made like 200
million dollars in the first weekend you
are in the minority no spider it was not
good now in comparison to good movies
but what about sauces do you like
spider-man - do I think it's a garbage
movie more or less and I've talked about
it at length on my channel if you
watched my videos but if yeah exactly
but back then what did you have to
compare it to Batman Forever The Phantom
Tank Girl hey hey hey hey do not knock
Billy Zane he was amazing in the Phantom
the shadow or the shadow is awesome and
Robin and then nip knots oh come on
nipple armor dude I'll never forget that
man nipples in the armor that was a good
idea there's multiple interviews of him
being like I wanted to sexualize Batman
I'm like don't I'm gonna Google nipple
armors even safer work that's a very
good idea yeah I've never seen him in
Florida gonna believe no it's just all
pasties okay um my one issue with the
movie is it's not really an issue so
much as the question it's okay so when
Scott went into the Microverse and then
came right back out it was like the
seconds from when he went into the
Microverse and so we didn't really get
to see has wasp
aged since she was in the Microverse in
which case how is she still alive
because she hasn't been able to eat or
drink
so I hear theories on that that you
don't age inside of there based upon the
fact that it felt like almost
instantaneous like
time passing for Scott I but outside you
could obviously see like things have
been cleaned up the cop had moved held
the girl cops from moving into the
building so I would go ahead and say
time doesn't pass well with the plan
highly answer that like they didn't say
did time actually passed it was just
he's shrunk down to the Microverse and
then at some point he's back and
everybody's leaving
if they really wanted to say time didn't
pass I would have appreciated it more
maybe a month had passed or even a year
had passed just yes I think what they
did was they loved it open because if
they leave it the way it is now and they
come back for the sequel they can do
Janet Van Damme if they want to and it
cast like a really hot young actress or
if they decide not to they can just do
some side thing bring her back however
they want leaving it open like this they
can kind of fill it in later
well you're playing like the Microverse
and Marvel Comics is basically like for
all intents and purposes is the exact
same thing as the earth-616 universe is
just yeah it's a real place with people
and like bright odds are like she's just
like chillin with micro people food yeah
it's it's it's literally I mean there's
been like there's a ton of people who
went there like when when Marvel wash
don't like I mean you had that you know
that went there Captain America went
there like imagine that's true that's
true but I guess think I'm brought it
back do what any I said well imagine if
the sequel like if they do get if we do
get an ant-man sequel and they go to the
Microverse in it this time yeah so real
world where people are there je demande
Dean's been like jailed up and time
doesn't pass oh she's a young beautiful
19 year old don't ever be married to
like the leader of the Microverse like
we have to remove her yeah
I will admit I spent half the movie
saying to myself is hope fund and that
one girl from Tron Legacy cuz they're
both the girl that was Van Dyne is
revenge on Lily but at the same time I
spent half of Tron Legacy going is that
Kara no from the AAA
like the entire movie just going like is
that this person like I get fixated on
my second character's going is that is
that them I'm really bad with
celebrities can that way then Oh fun
side note I and this I'm this is a great
segue off of a man I guess but uh I met
Mark Ruffalo just saying oh no need sure
with him that's cool let's just talk
about this isn't our muscle Ebony's
anyway yeah no that's I mean it's okay
here so here's a really cool thing the
idea of the microwave darkness what
Marvel Zombies um I think the really
cool thing about the Microverse is I
mean one like we don't even really know
if it exists or if it's only just he
went to a place between atoms right like
subatomic levels the Microverse may not
exist in Marvel because if mama comes
along and they say the Microverse exists
that opens up a whole new world like a
whole new plethora of things you know
because there's there's all kinds of
place and here's a problem that I would
have if they say the Microverse is real
then the Microverse becomes the model
cinematic unit universes version of the
ultimate universe of Marvel Comics well
we've got characters that we don't know
thinking exists
yeah like let's just like off to the
Microverse with you doesn't Marvel six
or six have a prison in the Microverse
no in the negative zone well they had
like they called it the big house it was
like a tiny prison for five major
supervillain prisons yes yeah oh yeah
there was the raft there was the vault
there was the 42 and there's the big
house
there's the kills amylase cookie yes I'm
gonna get these it's like how small is
that house like right here okay so
totally what else what did you guys
think about that good I thought I mean I
was can open a man will be completely
removed of the Avengers
how do you feel about them incorporating
the Avengers facility Falcon and then
incorporating him being all
already pretty much on the team you know
at first I did want it to be completely
removed from everything else but then I
thought about and I actually kind of
liked it because as the cinematic
universe expands more things are going
to cross over it's getting bigger and
bigger and so it wouldn't make sense
that it would be off on its own when
this world is all this universe is
becoming more and more populated at
least something would make it in there
from something that we've already seen
so I kind of liked that they chose
something that was so fresh and so new
in our minds by using the Avengers
facility yeah and that was my thought
you know my initial concern going in is
is it was literally gonna be a movie
with giant purple letters in every scene
saying oh by the way this isn't the same
universe as the Avengers
you know like everything's all it's all
happening at the same time but it
actually I mean it was it was done
quickly and tastefully and that's what I
think the difference is they basically
made the movie and they were like oh by
the way the Avengers are here and that's
it
why basically kept making you aware that
this isn't the universe like the joke
about the Avengers dropping cities or I
love it I love the lineup why don't we
call the Avengers you know that's the
first time they logically addressed that
issue that everyone always that every
everyone who comic book in existence
everyone who watches the movies
complains about that like an Iron Man
through the like what are yours cool
Avengers and friggin Thor to Wars cool
even like why did you call the Avengers
finally the character in the universe
acknowledging that annoying criticism
the Avengers because it's not called
Avengers three four and five and stick
it's called Thor - it's called friggin
Iron Man 3 because if they call the
Avengers the problem would be solved
that's why I was like an issue with
every Batman comic you know like Gotham
is gonna burn to the ground I mean like
I would like to see that every once in a
while like respite where like Batman's
being beaten literally to death his face
being caved and he just says like Clark
in the wall he's like I only do this
like every couple of years Thank You
Clark what's gonna happen in Ragnarok I
mean if you even buy the Ragnarok event
like for was like I need some help and
he called in Iron Man and Captain
America and so Piazza bleah happened
yeah that probably happen in the films
like cameo drops like basically like
what they're gonna get so bored it's
about Captain America he's going to be
the focal point but all the other guys
are here they're doing their thing now
yeah or like that utterly depressing one
in Thor two worth where Logan just looks
like Captain America for three seconds
and you're like that beautiful but
you're like because I was looking I was
looking at the casting for Thor - and I
was like wow Chris heavens
what are your legs gonna be doing you
know because pheno cameos you know that
part with this Stan Lee cameo wasn't
this movie you know you know that asian
girl in it yeah that was talking she's a
youtuber her name's Anna Akana and I was
just like watching that like for the
record further if they called up the
weekly poll I said we're just gonna pan
over you at a table you won't have a
speaking role we're there laughs and I
have a good time in a [ __ ] shoot re
just story I'm being said model if
you've got plans to make a Young
Avengers movie like Wiccan right yeah
we'll go into our post show we'll talk
about all the crazy Easter eggs and
stuff I'm sure anyone can watch videos
about these Trig's and if you haven't
yet go check out comic story TV a great
side project for me covers the severity
here is before we before we in this
here's here's what I love most about
ant-man like ant-man is a man is a
really cool concept of Marvel taking a
risk of model taking a gamble because
with Iron Man you could say well it's
kind of a gamble but it was a marvel
cinematic you wanna probably a few
others but brown Hornet 74 just
subscribe thank you thank you for
supporting the week people and every
single one of us we appreciate it yes
thank you for being part of this and if
I missed any
Goldman give me a list please um but no
like like you the really cool thing was
you know when Iron Man came out people
oh my god it's a movie babe like made by
Marvel it's gonna be good it's what
everybody want to go see it based on
that and so there was really no it was
really no gamble there with Iron Man we
knew there was going to be a success to
some degree it was just a matter of will
it be able to like uphold that will they
be able to keep keep going and so this
far into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
to Avengers films - Captain America
films - Thor films - Iron Man films and
so on
just say we're gonna make a movie about
a character that's never had a solo
series that has always been well I guess
he does now but has always been that
backdrop to the like that was basically
a weak hair - because Jim shooter said
it best when he took over for Marvel
Comics and and I guess is
editor-in-chief and when he was looking
at the character of a man and man was a
running joke like it was never taken
seriously he was always the first one to
lose who was always the first one to be
captured or in some capacity he was
always demonstrated as being the weakest
person on the team he's killed by a dead
guy digging this moment Luke strange
also subscribed during the podcast thank
you but no that's that that's it you
know when Jim shooter said he took over
like you know Hank Pym was a weak
character when ant-man camera I guess
when a Scott Lang came along he
inherited the role of a weak character
and so for model to come along and say
we're going to basically take over the
idea not only that to introduce the
concept of giant man because they did
that in the movie the enhance that
particular concept but we didn't get
much more out of it I mean I'm like I
agree that's probably where we're going
with this but like like the ability to
grow in size we think they introduce all
kinds of cool stuff there and and to be
able to take that movie to be able to
take that concept say we're gonna add
this in on the cusp of Captain America
civil war right after Avengers 2 age of
Ultron and with the direction that
everything is going in was a really big
gamble I think and it paid off because
it was a great combination of comedy and
action and and to me I think it's the
best movie they've had you know for so
low character in their first film since
Iron Man 1 I mean if I gave I said all
they care all the characters in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in terms of
their first films Iron Man and Men and
then you know Captain America Thor
whatever after that but you know it was
it was solid it was a great movie like I
really enjoyed it yeah yeah I agree I
know
I mean I've got multiple reviews and
discussions on my channels now at this
point but I loved the movie i-i-i
actually I'm a toss-up between that are
guarding to the galaxy's my favorite and
I like the two of them because they are
separate from everything you don't have
to have launched everything while I feel
like the main Marvel Cinematic Universe
we're getting to a point where it's like
alright star watch it from the start you
know thank you
well well made me happy in the fact that
this did well is that they're probably
gonna take risks on other characters and
you know there aren't any specific
characters Scarlet Witch I'd like to see
get there and maybe Scout village good
morale first yeah what she and she
getting our movie yes yes yeah I was
like when you brought that up because
you were talking about the Inhumans one
day and you said you were like you know
why Marvel's putting the Inhumans
between infinity war 111 and everyone's
like why is that because if they get the
rights back to x-men the Inhumans could
push back to the next if you look at the
back end of everything while that while
these deals are going yeah Black Panther
Captain Marvel in humans is the last
three yeah all those are getting pumped
if needed yeah yeah because if they get
Fantastic Four and x-men back you know
there will be at least I doubt they do
Wolverine movies but I can see a Cyclops
movie except I think they're gonna be
doing all they look at right now you
seeking stupid yeah who do I can see
them baby the only one of these movies
on this list that I can guarantee you're
gonna come out are all of the Avengers
movies yeah Thor movie obviously Captain
America has already done they're just
waiting to get it out damn guardians to
Doctor Strange I think is just
guaranteed at this point because it's so
close no but it's just it's just too
close they've all got everybody locked
in they've got Benedict Cumberbatch they
don't want to like wait for Benedict
Cumberbatch's popular to completely
dwindle off so get at that get it out
get I'm pretty sure I mean I'm pretty
sure Black Panthers almost locked in but
like if something happened tomorrow it's
definitely gonna get bumped you know
okay I think captain Marvel's and any
humans is gonna be the two that suffer
okay
okay here's one thing I want to like
before
before you into someone I want to
sidetrack for just a second the idea of
pistachio cucumbers playing Doctor
Strange was always weird to me because I
always felt like Adrienne kill and I
think the same was would have been a
much better like Doctor Strange than
then like pistachios I'm just saying
what he's really yes
like dude Eden in you ever if you don't
watch Game of Thrones or fortunately
anything he's been in he looks like dr.
Swain he looks like you would think
Doctor Strange would look like he minded
the way he would look Oh
Eagles 4201 just subscribes thank you
yes thank you so much I always feel like
for Doctor Strange you need an actor
that has a big presence about them that
you're gonna pay attention to but the
same time you can feel that they're
completely not a weirdo and I always
felt like if they were gonna do dr.
strange ideas odd for no apparent reason
there's always been a dr. strange in my
mind and it makes no sense but he's a
big weirdo and has a big presence about
him and all that I said I need and then
when I try and list big weirdos with a
big presence that actors in my mind he's
at the top of the list and Battenberg
kombucha cucumber patch or whatever his
name is is like nowhere near come why
does nobody know Benedict Cumberbatch's
name no man you know broken pots cuz I
went to school with the people that had
the name Cumberbatch and I don't like
them thank you so much for joining us
today we're gonna close at the main show
if you are joining us on Twitch which
you shoot every Tuesday at 6 p.m.
Eastern we are doing a post show we will
keep talking but our main show does have
to come to a close sadly we don't worry
next time we will condense down our
weekly reads discussion a little shorter
but don't forget to follow us at the
weekly pull on Twitter go to our
facebook facebook.com backslash the
weekly pull and make sure you go to our
website the weekly pulled on net to join
the community if you have managed to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much as directly supporting us the
creators of the weekly poll and very
soon for those of you guys who have
questioned me should you do twitch if
you can't watch
which don't worry we have a few other
things in the works that are becoming us
soon
so you can help support us and not waste
your money is something that won't
benefit you overall I think everyone
what's your opinion today a man loved it
I think it was awesome for your soul all
right next week we'll talk about the
Easter eggs if nothing else comes up
otherwise we're back guys
a dinosaur story anyway that was such a
good movie alright guys I've been in the
comic story and that is Rob from comics
explain that is sell from comic pop and
that is Faust from it's super effective
my voice is shot and I'm tired I'm gonna
go now but thank you guys and we are now
rolling to the post show everyone wave
so Rob knows when to cut the video later
does alright